we are here and it smells like fresh
Lobster come eat with me East Coast
station
welcome to my family's little getaway in
Prince Edward Island Canada's most
underrated Paradise now I'm hesitant to
share this all with you because I kind
of want this island all to myself but
there's really nothing not to love about
this place I mean other than the fact
that it FS up a blowout real damn fast
but the food
you can't go wrong so I'm going to take
you on a little culinary tour of some of
the things I got up to eating here in
PEI now of course a big reminder that
this is not a comprehensive exclusive
list of everything that I consumed in my
week here I mean I'm on holiday so I
didn't want to film every single morsel
food that I put in my mouth I wasn't
selective I was just forgetful if I
didn't film something or just didn't
feel like it because I had friends here
Etc it's also important to note that
what I ate this week is not necessarily
what I eat every day or every week the
food that's available to me here on the
island is quite different than what's
available to me at home and also my
needs are different when I'm on holiday
and I'm sitting on a beach most of the
day so please please please please do
not use this as a prescription of what
you should eat every body is unique and
if you need support speak to a dietitian
alright so let me walk you through a
week of eats on the island morning start
hello early here because that Sunrise is
aggressive AF
and my kids have major fomo so there's
always a coffee involved sometimes too
but at least always one
Paradise
breakfast was always something really
easy and fast and simple so sometimes it
would be like a yogurt or cottage cheese
parfait with like fruit and cereal on
top and I would go get like a pastry
with my kids afterwards sometimes it was
like frozen waffles that I put peanut
butter on top and I would have that with
Greek yogurt and some fruit
um sometimes it would be a big bowl of
protein and peanut butter oats with some
fruit that I'd have afterwards whatever
I could grab that was easy and also
something that my kids were probably
gonna be eating as well there was one
time I made like a fancy breakfast AKA I
made pancakes out of a red Fife pancake
mix that I got at a local Artisan place
here
um and that was really fun and easy but
I only did that because it was raining
that day and I had nothing better to do
with my time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
big dinner last night it was delicious
uh but not super hungry this morning so
I'm just having a little light brekkie
here some cottage cheese some
strawberries that my kids didn't want to
eat that I chopped up so I just picked
them out of their yogurt can't waste
them and put some cereal on top this is
like Life cereal which is surprisingly
delicious I kind of forgot about it and
I got a nice ripe nectarine so looking
forward to that just like a quick little
workout here
um
but one thing I just noticed was his
hair doing is the Red Sand has Stained
all of my shirts so I'm glad I didn't
bring anything too fancy all right
let's move our bodies
[Music]
[Music]
and it looks like I'm gonna be finishing
my clam shells here in the bedroom
because the kids want to play in my gym
so
I always get the shaft that's machine
it's a beautiful day today so it's going
to be a bit of a beach day as is
basically the whole week
and I'm the official schlepper of all
things as per usual AKA mom
you would usually spend the mornings
hanging out outside on the beach or on
the the deck just running around because
we actually had friends visiting us so
it was great to let the kids just play
together while the adults went for a
little stroll down the beach the beaches
here in PEI are so breathtaking and
blessedly silent I hate crowds on a good
day but in coveted times I definitely
don't want to be around a million people
on a beach so it's really nice to have a
nice quiet area to relax lunch was
typically like leftovers from the meal
that we had the night before sometimes
we would throw something simple on the
grill or we would make like a hodgepodge
meal of whatever we had left over in the
fridge just like make a little DIY
assembly style snack plate kids love
that I never wanted to waste like a
beautiful beach day in the kitchen
cooking so we usually had like a big
salad some rotisserie chicken frozen
Burgers corn veggies and dip uh leftover
pastries whatever we could spray round
job it doesn't matter how often I wash
my hair here it like instantly looks
dirty and disgusting but we just went
and picked up some oysters and some fish
for some dinner and I found these bad
boys
what this is the best the weekend low be
kinder yeah the Weekender this is like
an East Coast favorite and it's a
combination of sea salt and vinegar sea
salt and Cracked Pepper smoking sweet
barbecue and sweet and spicy jalapeno
and let me tell you it's the best chip
mix I've ever had
hmm
just killing time here folks before I go
back to the kids and I love them but I
need like
five minute breather some days we would
go on little adventures and of course
there was always really great food to be
had
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
so lunches around here are pretty chill
I'm basically just trying to use up
whatever we had like for dinner the
night before if we went out for dinner
we had leftovers we made something you
know we're just kind of making
hodgepodge meals around here and I feel
like that's just how I like to eat too
like I very rarely will cook a meal from
scratch when it's just like lunch also
when it comes to editing this I'm gonna
have zero clue what Clips are from what
day
because I'm changing my clothes like
literally five times a day and I only
have like five outfits so it's basically
just one marathon of eating no clue how
this video is gonna turn out but I'm
sure it's gonna be delicious
[Music]
another beautiful day in paradise I am
at a miniature petting zoo I don't know
I think the kids are just gonna have a
really fun time feeding the little baby
animals and hello my friend
I got a little baby goat here looking
for a meal
hello
let's get you guys in
I gotta go get some of the food to feed
them oh
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a drizzly day but the strawberries
are ripe for the Pickens so we're gonna
go pick some strawberries
[Music]
one for the bucket one for me
hmm
dinner was almost always Seafood because
we are right on the ocean it does not
get fresher than this but occasionally
we would like switch things up and Grill
up some chicken or meat there's actually
a fishmonger just down the road from us
like five minutes away so we would stop
by there and find out what he had gotten
in that day and that would determine
what we were making for dinner so we
would have like lobster oysters haddock
uh salmon you name it and we would serve
it super simply with just some potatoes
corn and veg so we're gonna do a classic
lobster dinner tonight I'm just slicing
up some lemons because I like lots of
lemon with my Lobster I'm boiling some
potatoes keeping it super simple
um and you know I've only cooked lobster
like live lobster maybe once or twice
before probably I think just here and it
was pretty straightforward but of course
I'm not an expert so hopefully it goes
okay I'm not gonna show it happening
because I feel like it might be
triggering for a lot of people
um so just know that I'm cooking them
myself but I will show you what it looks
like when it's done didn't get lobster
bibs
[Music]
once of course we did tacos because it
was a Tuesday and we had to like it's
Taco Tuesday so we served that with all
the fixings I feel like we literally
just ate lunch like an hour ago
but here I am
getting the grill ready to make dinner
so
that's kind of how we roll when you've
got kids it's basically like you're just
moving from one meal to the next and
yeah we're on to Taco night
I never get to do the grilling so this
is kind of fun for me
[Music]
and on a few occasions we got some date
nights out so we're gonna have a little
dinner here at the golf course because
it is a amazing night
[Music]
so I know I'm on vacation but
I still own a business so I'm just
trying to get everything ready for our
video to come out today communicating
with my team doing a tiny bit of work
while the kids are playing with the
grandparents
um I'm excited because we're going out
for dinner tonight just me and my Hubs
because it's our anniversary six years
that's right I think we've been together
for like almost 20 now which is crazy
um maybe not that long I don't even know
I've completely lost count apparently
um but anyways six years I think we've
been together for like 13 14. I have no
idea I don't even know how old I am
anymore
anyways it's been a long [ __ ] time
um so I'm excited for the rest of the
evening and for the rest of a lovely
week
[Music]
probably though the best meal on our
trip was Chef Michael Smith's fireworks
Feast which he hosts at his Inn at Bay
Fortune if you guys haven't been here it
is a must do for any foodie visiting the
island I think I've been three or four
times now it's amazing but make sure
that you book ahead
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
surprise
oh I feel like you guys
we do always oh my God and unless I had
dessert with my dinner I would almost
always have a bedtime snack so sometimes
I would do this kind of thing I invented
where I take whole grain wraps and I
fill them with Greek yogurt and put
berries in there it's kind of like like
a crepe experience but like a makeshift
crepe because I'm not making Crepes at
nine o'clock at night um anyways it's
delicious and it's a weird thing that I
like to do and sometimes I'd have
popcorn sometimes I would have like some
cottage cheese and fruit sometimes it
would be like a handful of chocolate
raisins because hello delicious hello or
one of my favorite Pei Staples are their
kettle chips they have a flavor called
the weekenders I think and it is
unmatched we know we know so I have to
say that my digestion has been really
really good here and I'm like racking my
brain trying to isolate the reason of
course it's really hard because there's
so many confounding factors but it might
be that my stress is better you know
like I'm sleeping better here than I
typically do at home it might be that
I'm eating a lot more kind of lean
protein maybe I'm eating fewer carbs
before bed but one thing I am pretty
sure of is that I'm needing less of a
bedtime snack and again that's not
because I'm less hungry so to speak I
believe it's because I'm less anxious
and it's often the anxiety about not
sleeping that encourages me to have a
large bedtime snack because I'm afraid
that hunger is going to wake me up in
the night and I've been able to kind of
just let go of that fear here and it's
feeling really good
um maybe that's it it's hard to know
that's my theory anyway but I feel
really good when I'm here so I kind of
just want to be here as much as I
possibly can and that my friends was a
lot of footage to try to organize I'm
sorry Brody it's gonna be a doozy to try
to edit that one yeah but if you guys
liked watching this Vlog more than Brody
probably enjoyed editing it don't forget
to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below on what kind of Vlog
content you'd like to see me do next
subscribe to the channel and I will see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]